on réalise aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle
une mission de siècle donc d'intérêt
économique général
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui nous
accompagnons sur les entreprises mais
aussi les compatriotes les martiniquais
sur des missions qui normalement aurait
dû être réalisée par l'état et l'état en
fait nous a mandatés pour accompagner
les publics sur la montrent leur montée
en compétences sur les outils numériques
donc ça passe par deux niveaux donc ici
sur cet espace ont fait de
l'accompagnement directement au public
et puis on travaille aussi sur l'aspect
ingénierie et création de la stratégie
d'inclusion numérique à la fois des
entreprises privées mais aussi des
entreprises publiques puisque nous
sommes en relation notamment avec les
opci de l'île est aussi d'autres entités
comme la sécurité sociale le pôle emploi
ou d'autres entités comme la caf avec
lesquels aussi qu'ils nous ont
complètement inclus dans leur démarche
d'inclusion numérique
la première chose que nous faisons avec
les personnes qui viennent sur l'espace
on leur fait un diagnostic
on parle toujours d'un diagnostic pour
comprendre voilà quel est le niveau
donc on a trois niveaux débutant
intermédiaire ou avancé
et puis en fonction de ces niveaux on
peut déjà proposé un accompagnement
sachant que le niveau débutant on va
commencer à la manipulation de la souris
l'utilisation du clavier et puis plus on
monte plus on apprend à mieux utiliser
les haussiers à mieux utiliser internet
par exemple lorsque il ya beaucoup
de nous de nous personne qui viennent
avec leur tablette
et dans ce cadre là plutôt que de former
sur les ordinateurs donc l'écran entre
guillemets normal là on va travailler
directement sur la tablette
on va leur installer des applications
dont elles ont besoin au quotidien comme
on pourra aussi installer des
applications plus ludique parce qu'il ya
aussi cette demande auprès des seniors
le côté ludique donc ça peut être des
jeux ça peut être aussi mieux utiliser
son adresse mail pour mieux communiquer
avec ses proches à l'étranger durant la
période des fêtes de noël on va vraiment
commencer cet accompagnement sur comment
identifier les sites viable donc comment
reconnaître un site où on peut
effectivement toute sécurité hc faire
ses achats en ligne
comment aussi identifier les offres les
bonnes offres sur internet parce qu'il
ya quand même ce qu'on appelle beaucoup
de d'offres illégal ou d'offre qu'on
appelle phishing qui sont plus fait pour
récupérer des informations personnelles
qu'autre chose donc on va un peu
commencé cet apprentissage autour de la
reconnaissance des des sites internet
complètement légaux de ceux qui sont
dans l'illégalité